So if there's anything that any of
us, I think,
realize as we build and scale
an AI led future for any of our
businesses,
it's the knowledge and reality that
platforms and foundations really matter.
And we've spent a lot of time in that
West thinking about the set
of shared capabilities
that are AI powered,
modern cloud native capabilities
that will underpin our AI powered
future. And this is what we call
our digital spine.
Our ambition as a bank is enormous
to be
the most customer centric digital
bank that is delighting
our customers every single day by reinventing
banking experiences
wherever they are
and at every point of need.
And we're doing that across 33 big
strategic pillars. The first is delivering growth,
of course.
So we're very fortunate that each of our businesses,
from our core retail bank to our commercial
institutional bank, which you'll hear from Jen a
bit later,
to our wealth bank, our mortgage business.
All of those businesses are growing, and they're growing
because we're because we're investing in our customers.
We're investing in that hyper personalization
that can only be delivered through AI.
Secondly, we're simplifying our bank, but we're
not simplifying it for its own sake.
And I think many a transformation has been
and gone and failed
simply because simplification and rationalization
exists
to reduce the numbers.
For us, simplification is about outcomes. It's
about value delivered to our customers,
and it's in service of those great
AI powered journeys that we're delivering.
And then finally, of course, we're a bank, so
we have to focus on better managing our
capital assets and we do that
through a really significantly
scaled data transformation
journey that we're on.
And all of those things are building our digital
spine.
And let me
pick out some highlights of of that spine.
Firstly, integration.
You'll know that within the financial services
sector, we're an ecosystem where
we need interoperability. We're connecting
with payments with
third parties, with counterparties.
So integration really matters and
um our AI power bank
is, is, is built
on secure connectivity for what
are really truly AI orchestrated services.
Secondly, our data marketplace, and some of you may
have heard of that in other sessions
this last few days, but where data fuels
the insights and models of our
AI ecosystem,
and really building and scaling a data
fabric anchored around a mesh architecture
that that enables that AI
powered bank.
Simplification really to us is about
building an AI driven intelligent core
banking platform.
That delivers adaptive and personalized
products, all enabled by AI.
And then finally,
resource management, of course, is about a
scaled AI ecosystem that
enables every single employee in the bank
to achieve more.
And we're really proud of our digital spine.
We're really proud of the way that we're
infusing AI into every single
component of that architecture that
is really building the foundations of
an AI powered digital future.
So how are we doing this then? So we're, we
have delivered and developed an AI reference
architecture.
Uh, and we see that architecture across
four tiers.
It would be remiss of me not to
to call out the reality that this isn't a
technology problem, of course.
We're incredibly fortunate
to be in our industry right now at
a time of enormous disruption where
technology is no longer the inhibitor.
And the the joy and excitement of being
here at Reinvent, I think has really brought that into
focus, hasn't it, that
what's limiting us as businesses, as
individuals, is our imagination.
We're no longer constrained by the technology.
But to achieve those outcomes,
we need an operating model that scales and an
operating model that is fit for an AI powered
future. Where
controls
are there, and where we've established an AI
ready culture.
And that's also where partners come in.
I think as in scale transformation
of this,
of this extent, partners really matter.
And you know, we're delighted to be partnering
with Emphasis, um,
a really important partner for this journey with us
who show up every single day with
awesome people,
fantastic ideas, and, and
in no baggage, no strings attached,
just aligned to our outcomes.
So partnerships really matter, and selecting those
purposefully is is part of the journey.
Our core tech and data fabric, I've talked a lot about
that, but, you know, really focusing on integration,
on security and scale
in a agentic world where
access to trusted, secure, reliable data
is, is the
cornerstone of success. And then
where the magic really happens is the third layer,
which is our
AI powered decision making.
Where we're building the products, where we're
scaling agentic solutions and
enabling
um the magic to happen for our customers
and uh and then finally digital
engagement, which is all about.
And AI ready ready interfaces
and really focusing on that integration and
intelligent products and services. And,
and that for me is the exciting bit where we can
build and deliver AI
infused products for our customers that really
make a difference to them every day.
Uh, and then I'll, I'll,
I'll finish by
talking a little bit about how we see
the use case portfolio across
our banking ecosystem and, and
how we're really thinking about scaled
AI across,
um, across our entire ecosystem for our
customers and,
and that's across 4 areas and
we see
a set of use cases as a, as
a value chain really,
um, starting at the very bottom with,
you know, scaled AI.
End user, low code,
use cases that are for everybody, personal
productivity, and that for us is the foundation
of everything that we're doing,
really building and scaling the capability
of every single employee to achieve more for
our customers.
Secondly, commodity driven use cases.
So those small little AI use cases
built by our amazing engineers
using AI generated
software engineering practices,
but those, those point use cases,
that too is the bedrock of our AI journey.
And then moving up the values value chain
is
complex firsts.
So those were those set of agentic services
that require orchestration, automation,
autonomy
require intervention.
Um, that we're really investing in
heavily with our engineering teams. And,
and then finally,
leading edge research.
So we see that in order to
really win with customers, then the
way to do that is to invest heavily in
the, in the capabilities that
don't yet exist. And
we're very fortunate to have a really powerful
and strong AI research team
who are looking into things such as deep fake
protection,
um, avatars, biometrics,
etc.
I'll just finish though by saying,
um,
It goes without saying, I suppose, that in
a world where every institution, every
organization, yours and mine,
will have access to powerful AI
where AI is no longer
where technology is no longer the inhibitor,
competitive advantage doesn't come just
from the technology.
It comes from partnerships. It comes from
culture. It comes from enablement
of people. It comes from
hiring the best talent.
And our journey towards a world class
AI driven future
for our customers. It starts
with our people.
And with that, I'll hand over straight to the next
speaker. I
get the click. Thank
you, Diana, and thank you, Manish for that
introduction.
Um.
Hello everyone, I hope I'm audible.
My name is Maithili Madira.
I'm an SVP of technology. I work
for a
broker dealer called LPL Financial.
I'm New York based,
and I'm really glad that we got
this chance to sort of connect on this
core topic
after those exciting sessions and
the key notes that we've had in the last
two days.
Um,
this is AWS Reinvent, and I'm really
honored that we could be part of the forum. And
thank you to our Infosys partners for
inviting me to speak here today. This
is where our innovation meets execution.
So, and I'm excited what our teams can
do. The first thing
I want to touch upon here is when Infosy
asked me on this topic,
you know, throughout my career, I've worked
in financial services for at least the
last two decades, and we've done all sorts
of transformation.
And probably all of you can relate to
that work for, you know, work activities,
right? We've taken our monolith
systems, we've migrated,
you know, to microservices,
we've basically, you know, moved workloads to
the cloud,
all of that
and brought some efficiencies to our
businesses,
but all of that was taken with a digital first
hat.
Now we get to do all of this value chain
keeping AI as the core engine.
And guess what? If you don't incorporate
AI, people will call that an upgrade.
It's no longer a transformation. So that's
really the key, you know, point here.
We are at a place of paradigm
shift, and we're super excited
that we bring that to a certain industry,
despite we have a lot of regulations
and put that with the right guard leaders and
governance.
So, with that context,
let me take you to the firm.
So I work for a firm LPL Financial.
We're the largest
broker dealer in the US,
you know, we're a Fortune 500 firm,
and one of the top RIA custodians.
And we have definitely a very
large user base, which is financial advisors.
We serve about 32,000 of them in
the US market.
Um, you know, our firm,
uh, AUM is around 2.3 trillion,
and we support 8 million US households
today. So that's, that's the
space that we are in.
Our leadership mission and vision is
to be the best wealth management firm.
So this is coming top down, right? That
is the leadership aspiration.
And in order to get there,
the key thing I want to point out is, unlike,
you know, you know, I worked in other financial
institutions and banks where your customer
becomes your primary persona
that you support.
LPL is slightly different,
you know, and, and why I say that is
LPL is an advisor centric firm.
We focus on the financial advisor. That's
where our value proposition is.
We want advisers to be equipped with the
best in class tools so they
can support the. Financial goals
of our end customers, that's where
you know we fit in in in the broader
context we support various
institutions and we offer capabilities
to strengthen that element,
particularly why that is key is we're
talking about AI and digitizing
capabilities, but the thing to
recognize here is
this is a particular industry where
the human element becomes even more
important where we where we are looking
at digitization.
And why I'm stressing that particular point
is,
with an LPL,
think about it, when do you need financial advice
the most?
You need that in moments where you're making
life changing decisions,
you need to unders you want the assurance
and you want the confidence to take that next
leap. You want to be able to use
these advice and get that
confidence from a trusted advisor, and that's
the value proposition an LPL advisor
brings. And what we want to strengthen
with our AI platform and tools is
make sure that. Advisors get the, the
gift of time so they can focus on
that relationship,
help their customers in moments that matter.
Moments where there's market volatility,
moments where your clients have high liquidity
needs, and not really focus on,
you know, administrative overload,
which tends to be some of the challenges we're
solving in this journey,
particularly for our wealth advisors.
I also want to take you through
our next slide, which,
and you know, this is basically,
you know, you don't have to read the entire thing, but
the context here is these are
the various news articles that have come
up in the last couple of years about
LPL.
And what I want to call out is, in the
last 3 to 5 years,
LPL as a firm
has doubled its AUM.
There are not many firms that grow in that
level of scale, and that's the
criticality here.
Not only there is scale, our stock
price has grown 351%.
Our adviser base has doubled in,
in the short 2+ years that I've
been there.
So, so for you to recognize that, you
know, we are supporting a platform
with an active user base,
our investor portal, which is one of the areas
that I manage.
Has about, you know,
2 million active users with a
projection of doubling that in the next couple
of years so there is tremendous
growth so the strategic levels that
this firm
has focused on are not just the organic
traditional growth model we're talking
about inorganic M&A and
aggressive M&A
so which explains why. My AI capabilities
are a core and crucial
in this type of transformation.
So that's,
um, I just want to pause here and ask the audience
question before we sort of
talk about the next piece.
Is there anybody here who thinks
that their industry will
not have to redefine the transformation journey?
Show me a hand.
OK, I made my point.
You know why.
All right, and I'm excited that we get to
build that together right as a group here.
So the four personas, so you
know, my, you know, our approach and sort of
solving this,
you know, AI first and AI led
journey is looking at the personas
we support
and I, I genuinely felt our brand
campaign was stolen by the way, the AWS
keynotes. Speaker, because what if we
could is LPL's brand
brand campaign just so everybody knows so
think about the persona first here which
is John who's the financial adviser
and what if we could make their life
about serving their clients
having you know showing that empathy and
trust in the relationship angle which is
what they excel about.
We don't need to,
you know, give them the administrative aspects
of, oh, you know, you have to manage your transactions
and support them through the day. They should be focused
on relationship advice,
give proactive personalized
information and faster response.
So we want to give them speed and personalization.
So that is the gift we want to solve with AI.
Think of our end investor.
So and and that is a persona probably
all of us wear, right? If you all have
bank accounts,
yeah, you know the end investor persona
and what do an end investor expects
from them? They want trust they want transparency
from their, you know, financial
institution they want seamless digital
experiences and most importantly,
including myself, they want outsized returns
and that's the piece we want to demonstrate.
And think of the 3rd persona, my most
favorite, because I wear the payments,
you know, hat in our organization.
And I can tell you, if you've ever worked
in operations,
you will understand this.
So, operations role, you know,
especially in the wealth management and financial services
industry, Has not digitized and
we haven't necessarily, I think,
you know, leverage AI to the level
that you could in terms of strengthening
the, you know, automation and the
operation, like taking out the manual workload
and the friction. So there's a great opportunity
for us to solve it.
And the last, as a technology
leader, core and you know, the
most personal
piece in this is we want to give time
back for our developers to focus on
innovation and not really routine
tasks.
My two favorite tasks I really, really hope
we can digitize very soon,
getting rid of that pen test, the manual
pen test, and release management.
You know, make sure that
nobody has to use Jira and focus
on innovation.
So that's, that's, that's the gift we want, we are aspiring
to give. So,
you know, I'll just take you through. So, any,
any of these transformations, as you can see,
right, you have to start small.
You know, demonstrate those quick wins
and then you march into
a longer sort of, you know, iterative
journey and strengthen that.
So I want to take you through 4 such
use cases that are right now
in the works
and have become sort of crucial
for us to illustrate on the KPIs
and see how we can measure the impact of
AI AI and digitization at
LPL. So the first one is our. Banking
wizard. I'm sorry because I can't
really zoom into the content, but I
can talk through there
so this is a tool
where we have an Amazon, you know,
uh, Bedrock LLM behind the scene
that connects to our knowledge base like Jira
Confluence,
and in essence this was built
by our banking team because we just launched
our flagship cash management
account. So LPL supports a lot of
investment products
insurance. Products but most recently
we've launched our banking solutions,
um, and this
was launched within a year, right? And
I'm really incredibly proud of that win because,
you know, bringing a product to life
especially in in that short window
and making sure it is launched successfully,
you know, it it it the only we could do is
with the tools like AI that can improve our
productivity and get us to the outcomes
we need. And what's important with
this particular product is
we've been able to showcase that, hey, there
is an
information layer that we can provide to
our service partners so that every time they
need to understand who's eligible for
this account,
where does thing, where do things stand, there
is a tool for them.
Need to really like reach out to their
product or support or multiple layers of the
organization and that's the OR and efficiency
it was able to accomplish.
The second one, which is account view, um,
and this is an effort that's massively in
progress. Socount View happens to be LPL's
customer facing investor portal.
And what we are trying to do that in that
particular space is,
we have close to 160+
endpoints, we're supporting a portal
and a very vast user base,
and that is the one we want to take through a
digital transformation journey. A lot
of our code,
you know, templates and,
libraries are being transformed. And
for most of you who've migrated
workloads to cloud, you probably would have
seen, you, you know, about the 7
hours, right? And we have probably most
of those in that platform. It's not just
a lift and shift. So there's a massive rearchitecture
as well.
And AI has been incredibly useful for
us in that journey.
The next one is there are net new capabilities
that we are launching, lending being
one of those
operations, which I spoke about is one of the persona
that massively has
manual surveillances and manual
review document review, and that is
an area that is of key focus,
which we are. Strengthening using,
you know, agents. And the last one
is developer efficiencies.
So we have a lot of opportunities
and some of the developers are in this
room, which I'm excited to see, especially
folks who are using cursor, co-pilot,
and, and a lot of the bedrock solution.
So these are the teams that are able to leverage
the power of these things and
especially use them for test automation,
generation of code,
and which we are incredibly excited to see
and what that could bring.
I'll take you through a couple of, you know, futuristic
use cases that are right now in the incubation,
and the reason why they're interesting is
the potential it can solve for our firm. For
example, like we're we're looking into a payment
exception handler,
given the operations overhead that we
have, something that can resolve the exceptions.
Let, let's call that payment superhero.
The next one is we're talking about our co-pilot
for our back office team.
So, and this is something, you know, that's
really critical, especially there's a lot of
information and acronyms that they need to look up,
and we could use that.
And then the very last one, which is an area
I think I've heard from the other panelists
as well, is the opportunity here
to solve financial crimes, the fraud monitoring,
and making sure we can do our anti-money laundering
using AI. So those are the things that are in the
works.
Like all transformation goals, I
want to make sure that we talk about a critical
topic, especially in an industry where
we are highly regulated, which is our governance
and controls,
and we are trying to execute the strategy
with the right governance model, ethics,
guard rails, and compliance
tools so that we can make sure we deliver
it right,
because trust in this industry is non-negotiable.
So that's really where we are.
And then to sum it up, right? So
I want to make sure that we bring
this whole story together.
So we just talked about
that LPL is committed to deliver differentiated
services to our customers.
We want to bring that through personalization.
We want to digitize the entire experience.
We've talked about the tremendous growth story
there and how we have, you know, the AUM
and the affiliation models
that we need to support. So that is where
we are using the power of AI. The tools
to support that.
Operation simplification is a critical
area and there's a lot,
lot of opportunity there that we could strengthen.
And finally, bringing technology to
the forefront, right? And how you achieve that
in a scalable, sustainable way.
I want to put this thought to
everybody. You know, when we
talk about transformation, right,
you know, AI is, you know, probably
the lever we are using. Think of it, you're
launching your rocket ship,
you have your greatest tech stack, you're
finding the right business problem to solve.
AI is your fuel.
If you don't introduce that, your rocket's
not taking anywhere.
So just make sure, you know, you keep that in
mind. I would love to hear
from this group on where you, where
things stand. Is your rocket, rocket
in your space station, or is it
basically,
you know, launched and in outer space.
So I look forward to hearing from these
folks in this room, and thank you.
That was, uh, pretty impressive, uh, stats
about LPL and all that. I don't, I work for Truist,
uh, we're, uh,
we're, uh,
we're on a similar journey, on a similar journey with,
uh, digital and AI transformation. We're coming
out of a pretty
significant merger of two regional
institutions, so it's, uh.
More even more important, even more pivotal for
us to adopt AI, adopt, uh,
you know, digital transformation, but, uh,
we're, we're focused on, uh, serving
multiple clients. We,
we, we run multiple businesses, mortgage,
digital banking,
uh, commercial lending, payments,
uh, wholesale banking, wealth management. We're
about a $570
billion institution. Um,
Trust is,
but, uh, so thank you very much for the
opportunity today. Uh, excited to be here.
Thank you Infosys uh for, for hosting
us. Uh, what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna, I'm gonna talk about, um,
the,
I'm not gonna talk about the use cases. I'm gonna
talk about our blueprint for AI strategy
from a technology standpoint.
Anybody
who has run platforms and capabilities probably
can relate to this. We're always one tool away from
greatness, right? Just get that one tool
we'll be in business,
uh, by the way, this is, uh, proprietary and
it is, uh, you know, you're gonna have to
pay me a cent to use it every time.
So, uh, we, we, while I'm, while I'm
exaggerating a little bit,
um,
I'm not really exaggerating, right? You know, we were
in, uh, uh, uh, one of the greatest conferences
in the world
for 2, for a couple of days.
How many new capabilities have come out? We have
seen so many capabilities come out and
everything is moving at lightning pace. I mean, literally
at lightning pace, I think.
So we have to, we have to focus on integrations.
That's the name of our game.
We are trying to, uh, we're just talking to,
you know, we're just talking to the Nat NatWest
partners here.
Do you take the data to the AI or do you take
AI to the data? That's, uh, you know, I
don't know, I literally a billion dollar, billion
dollar question,
but, uh, we are trying to, our,
our, uh, strategy
has been to move in the, in
the direction of faster integrations,
um.
And um
This is sort of like how we're anchoring
our overall approach to
uh to run uh you know we want to
be able to accelerate our use case
backlog and for us to be able to
do that um we are looking at
a multi-pronged approach
that allows, you know, for us to choose the right
tools for the right job at the right,
you know, sort of like pace as well
so we are heavily, heavily again we are heavily
focused on integrations we want to scale
AI we want to bring
everything cohesively together so we're focusing
on. Uh, an enterprise blueprint
that can bring all these things together. So
the way we see it, right, the way we see sort of like,
uh, generative AI, genetic A, all of these
things, I can probably put it in three categories.
One is our own personal knowledge
domains. We have
the places we work at have. Tremendous
knowledge domains. It could be, it could be ticketing
data. It could be Jira. It
could be anything.
Uh, there's tremendous amount of knowledge domains
to be built out and we want to implement, you know,
use cases on top of those things. So
we were, we're treating those as, as, as one
particular domain
and then there are so many other products that enable AI
you, you have to be able to adapt to those
products as well.
There are platforms. Platforms come with every
single, you know, entity, every single
sort of like, um, uh, application,
every single product,
everything has AI enablement. You have to be
able to
take advantage of all of these things and you have to
be able to do it intelligently again
through integrations.
So, um,
just a little bit of an eye chart, but kinda,
kinda, you know,
what I've tried to do here is to highlight.
Uh, on the left, you're gonna, well, on
my left, I guess, uh.
Yeah you're gonna see like the uh
the um
enterprise blueprint
uh for uh generative AI solutions
and on the right here to my right you're gonna see
you know uh a blueprint for uh traditional
AI. What we wanna try and
do here is we want to, we want to
uh have
an enterprise knowledge domain that
powers both of these things. We want to be able
to invest
heavily and provide.
You know, super critical, really good
experiences for the knowledge domain experts
for them to be able to bring in the knowledge,
manage it, curate it,
make it available for not only for
models but also for generative AI solutions.
So we're focusing heavily on the
experience for the knowledge experts as well.
So that's the sort of like the, the.
Bedrock, you know,
uh, for, for a, for a lack of a better term, that's, that's,
that's what is driving everything for us under
there. And then from there, you know,
we have 3,
I'm, I'm not gonna read through all of these things. You can look
at it. We have a platform layer that is focused
on, you know, sort of leveraging
the enterprise platforms that are available. We,
we use, you know, we're sort of like trying
to be
as agnostic as possible, but, you know, we
use things like Bedrock and Sagemaker,
uh, pretty heavily for our, uh, for our,
um. Model development as far
as well as for our um um
generative solution development.
Where we have a component layer in between
that helps with orchestration that helps with
sort of like trying to pull everything together
component wise and then we have a
framework where we can bring different types
of experiences. For example, if you want a rag
use case, you, you can, you can sort of like
bring the rag use cases in there.
You can bring agentic platforms and get them integrated
there if you want to move towards MCPs,
you can get those. Integrated as well. So this is
the direction in which we are trying to move
and as well as, you know, when you, when you go to the traditional
model development side,
we want to have, uh, an experience of the people
that train the models as well. It's not just a
question of serving up the models for
applications to use. We have to have a platform for
the model training as well. So
we're trying to put all of these things
under a common UI.
We want, uh, a good distinctive,
uh, reliable use, uh, field
for all of these things. So we're trying to prioritize that
experience as well.
Uh, for the people that are developing
the models, for the people that are developing knowledge
bases. So this is, this is
the enterprise blueprint that we're looking at.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna kinda summarize
all of these things, um,
this is again, there's a lot of words in here,
but we are,
we are trying to use native AI, we're
trying to use vendor enabled AI, we're trying to use
platform enabled AI.
And we want to bring everything together.
We want to scale. We want to have the
right tool for the right platform
for the right use case.
So whether it is a question of, you know, leveraging
Cortex from Snowflake, the ability
to do that, or whether it's a question of leveraging,
you know, automation platforms that have embedded
UI, so or embedded automation,
sorry, embedded AI,
we're trying to bring all of those things together
and we want to scale. Like I want
to close this. I wanna close this, and I wanna talk
about like. we are,
we are prioritizing
integrations to, to drive
our 150+
use cases backlog,
and the only way to do that is to be able
to, is to be able to scale.
We're prioritizing scaling,
cohesiveness and using the right tool for
the right job for us.
Thank you.
I. So,
hi there, thank you, thank you for having me.
Um, so my name's Jennifer Scott and I
look after the digital banking platform for
the commercial and institutional franchise
within NatWest.
So NatWest, as Diana said, is a
leading UK bank,
uh, that focuses on retail,
business, and wealth customer base.
The commercial and institutional franchise
specifically focuses on our business customers,
so we serve
business customers all the way from small SMEs
up to large,
um,
institutional clients.
My role there really as head of engineering
of the digital platform
is to look at
our customer and our colleague digital journeys,
uh, and in particular, we're focused on the transformation
of a platform called Bankline
today.
Um, so I'll, I'll talk to you a little bit about that.
So what is Bankline? Bankline is
a digital platform that allows
customers to access
accounts and payments capabilities
across three channels, so mobile, web,
and API.
Typically our smaller
SME businesses will interact with the
mobile platform, um, then
our mid-market,
uh, corporate treasury functions will,
will access the, the web platform.
They'll also use the mobile platform,
uh, for mobile payments, checking balances
on the go, etc.
um, and then our
more larger institutional customers
will connect to us via our API
platforms.
The customers that we service typically
have a turnover in the range of 7500
to 500 million.
Um,
the platform is, is, is
critical in serving that customer base.
At the end of 2024,
we had approximately
370,000 users, and
we were processing transactions in and around
circa 27.6 million
um per month.
So it's a fairly, it's a fairly critical platform.
It was launched in
1995.
So, you know, over the last three decades,
it has been a cornerstone of our
success.
Um, but obviously, during that time, both
customer and
technology has really evolved dramatically.
So, today, customers
expect to interact with us over digital
ecosystems.
They want a digital experience that,
um,
Is both connected, intuitive,
you know, easy to use.
That's effectively what we want to deliver with this
transformation.
So our ambition
to achieve that digital experience that our customers
want,
and also to ensure that we have a platform
for the future,
we created 3 strategic objectives
to steer the transformation work.
So the first one, digital customer journeys,
looks to deliver a unified
customer experience
across
all of the journeys, uh, that our customers
use, um.
Covering both mobile web and API.
The single point of access piece is basically
looking to provide frictionless access
to our products and services.
So through Bankline,
accessing more products and services from behind
a single logon.
And the third one,
increased pace of delivery.
So how can we, through the
technology transformation through a migration to cloud,
look to deliver more capability more often
to our customers?
So, a really key point for us
was thinking about the transformation, not just in the
context of the technology that we
want to move to, but how do we continue
to deliver value for our customers.
And that's obviously critical in terms of
Um,
the customer experience keeping our
business stakeholders, you know, engaged
and supportive across, across the transformation
duration,
um, so, so fairly critical. So
in terms of doing that, we created some sort of
simple, powerful indicators to track
both our progress and also the value that
we're delivering to customers.
The first one of those was a percentage of
the customer journeys that
um have been modernized that have
received, uh, you know, the digital experience
has been updated for our customers.
The second of which
was the number of customer journeys that we've actually
migrated to cloud.
And the 3rd,
the number of products that we've integrated
through Bankline and sit behind that single log
on. We,
we sort of focused as well on trying to
think about what are the table stack capabilities
that our customers would expect from a commercial banking
platform, um, and that
sort of drove us to prioritize,
uh, solving for customer pain points
and actually looking to reduce
our reliance on our customer
support desks as well.
So,
Over the course of the last two years, I think
the results really speak for themselves. So,
you'll see on the slide here, the sort of the 4
sort of 4 main points surround progress to
date. So,
digital service requests have increased
by 60% over the course of the last 2
years. So
our customers are having sort of faster, more
efficient interactions with us.
We've delivered a single platform for,
for mobile
that covers all of our, um, brands
that allows us to do updates more quickly.
And have a consistent offering to our
customer base.
Um, we've integrated key products,
uh, through the bank line platform. So,
for example, asset finance,
um, foreign exchange,
um, corporate credit cards, to name a few.
So, you know, they're more readily accessible,
uh, and actually reducing friction and, and
really keeping customers within our ecosystem,
which is, um, beneficial for all.
And all of that's been underpinned by that continued
delivery through of customer workloads
onto cloud.
Um, that sort of underpins all that capability.
So the key to unlocking
the transformation has been
migrating to a
cloud architecture.
Um,
the complexity that we faced when
we started the program was having a,
you know, sort of very manual,
a very legacy code base,
um, you know, that's been compiled over decades,
having manual deployments into
production that take quite a long period of time,
and also having a very long lead time, uh,
of delivery of value to customers.
So the process,
so the solution to all of this really was to move
to a cloud architecture
that would give us that
faster delivery,
um, increased resilience across
the platform, and also the ability to
have capacity on demand.
So we adopted a repeatable
approach that saw us focus on pilot
customer journeys to begin with.
These were really designed to
increase our learning, um, across
the developer community, but also
to build confidence as, as we went,
um, and then we migrated to more
critical applications.
Releasing more complex capability, for
example, multi-site resiliency
to support those journeys,
and then, uh, we delivered a
uh internal developer platform which
allowed our developers to,
um, you know, deploy independently
and safely, which is critical in achieving
that agility of uh release
cadence.
So overall, uh, we've had
much faster deliveries. Uh, we've had,
you know, much greater resilience across the platform.
We're aiming to be, you know, sort of zero downtime
by the time we reach the end of the transformation.
And,
um, we've been able to experiment safely.
So progressive
releases, AB testing,
all the while sort of maintaining regulatory confidence
in, in what we're doing.
I'm, I'm finally,
uh,
talking about how we've used AI to sort of accelerate
the transformation. So we've done that in 4 key ways.
The first code analysis, so.
Reviewing all of those complex legacy
code bases,
producing dependencies,
dependency maps across those so our developers
can understand the landscape,
documentation generation, so providing structured
context aware
documentation that
are Again, our, our, uh,
developer community,
you know, can,
can interact with that documentation and really
understand the code base that they're transforming.
Migration planning,
so using AI insights
to phase the deliveries,
um,
bringing into that business priorities
and code complexity so that we've got, you
know, uh,
a safe way of, of executing the migration
plan. And finally, code refactoring.
So conversion of those
legacy code bases to modern
code bases.
Again, you know, producing code
that is understandable, maintainable as
we go forward is fairly critical.
So I think those four things really combined
to reduce the complexity that we've had to deal with,
you know, shorten the timelines of the delivery,
um, allowing the developers, I think has
been mentioned before,
you know, to focus on delivering customer value
and.
Uh,
yeah, just effectively, you know, delivering
that digital experience that we want to and
not spending our time
untangling decades old code
bases.
So I think, um, in summary,
the transformation has been more than
just a technology transformation. It's been
how can we deliver the digital experience that
our customers need
and also how do we deliver a
platform that's ready for the future
and meets our needs going forward.
So thank you for your time.